what we want to have a look at is the
kind of questions the kinds of areas we
can explore in terms of understating
geometry with all these new fancy
polynomial techniques that we've
developed so we understand how
polynomials work we understand what a
single double triple root are we
understand how to use some a product of
roots but it's not just a quadratic ok
so what we want to do is say how can we
use those techniques not just to solve a
problem about well tell me what the sort
of root are but how can we use it in an
actual application as it were now I'm
deliberately starting with a question
that we can do without a such polynomial
techniques because if I gave you this
question and tell you what it was about
I think you could work out every part of
it it's a fairly long question but you
know enough calculus you know enough
coordinate geometry to do all of these
things but what I'm going to try and
show you today is that with the
polynomial techniques that we have
developed number one you've got
you just have another way into these
questions and number two these other
ways often a faster and more flexible
they offer you a way to get into
questions that you wouldn't get
otherwise can we girls hurry up okay so
let's just quickly have a look at the
set up and there we'll back on the
questions thinking about how we will use
these polymer your techniques we just
developed in a straight line you got a
parabola and we're told that they
intersect at a couple of points right if
they if we named those points for
intersection a and B then can we find
all these things that relate to a and B
you'll notice I put in our blanks here
for the coordinates of a and B and
that's because we can name them if you
think back to yesterday remember I told
you on what if you are cubic and the
polynomials roots are an AP do you
remember that if they go in order like
alpha alpha plus the difference alpha
plus more differences so I can call
these things whatever I want but I want
to phrase it in a way that makes this
easy to solve okay how do you normally
find points of intersection again going
back to what you know before you would
take these two equations you would solve
them simultaneously okay now just have a
look at what equations they are when you
solve equation one and equation two
hideously what kind of equation do you
create you've got degree one degree two
using our polynomial language when you
put them together well you saw
simultaneously what degree we have it'll
be degree two that makes this doesn't it
because you basically have two x equals
that and that's a quadratic okay really
good so being that we're going to have a
quadratic to solve to find these points
of intersection those two solutions to
that quadratic are going to be my points
of intersection in other words there'll
be roots of a quadratic the two x values
right and we usually call roots when
you've got a quadratic you is using
called alpha beta okay so I'm going to
call the x coordinates of our points of
intersection alpha beta now I could call
the y corner it's something completely
random okay like introduce more letters
or something like that but I don't have
to because I know that if these points
of intersection are between this line of
this parabola then at the very least
they must both wireless line
does that make sense if they really are
points of intersection intersection it
should be on this line well if the
x-coordinate of this is alpha and it
lies on this line then what's the
y-coordinate it's two alpha again
because y is literally two times the x
value which is alpha in the same way
this is better and to be done okay so
you can see this is a better way of
saying rather than like four different
unknowns that I've got I've only got two
hundreds now for a better and the Y's
relates that okay so now how am I gonna
start to think about this find the
midpoint of a B well without polynomial
techniques I would need to do something
like actually fired what all these
coordinates are and then I have to use
the midpoint formula and then off I go
okay but think about this how would I do
this with polynomial techniques well
I've got some roots here right what
kinds of things do we normally do when
you see alphas and betas and gammas what
are the it's a quadratic what are the
two things you can quickly calculate out
of a em out of a quadratic you can do
the summer you can do the product right
now I'm going to use both of those but
watch what happens if
get the product if I say sorry at the
Sun if I say the Sun right alpha plus
beta how is this thing which I know is
very easy to find it how is it useful to
me in finding the midpoint
what is the midpoint formula it's going
to be alpha plus beta or two that's
gonna be the x coordinate and then it's
gonna be 2 alpha plus 2 beta onto that's
the y coordinate right hold on a second
two alpha plus 2 beta or two why am i
doing on two again I'm putting the
middle some average e right
what TF of those two beta on - isn't
that equal to alpha plus beta so do you
see just by using this sum of roots
result I can go immediately to the y
coordinate no I didn't even need to know
what the Y coordinates of these things
are I can go straight there right do you
ever mention to you before like why do
we care about these things well
sometimes we want to get these results
without having to go through what our
alpha beta in the first place and this
is a perfect example okay so now we've
got a bit of an idea of how we're gonna
go through this questions let's start to
solve the thing okay you told me this is
part a you told me to start solving this
thing simultaneously so I get this x
squared minus 2x minus 8 equals 2x okay
so the solutions of this thing are alpha
and beta yeah let's tidy this up a
little bit so to make it one quadratic
I'm subtracting this from both sides
okay and from this this is my quadratic
in general form okay so I can read off
my alpha plus beta here as what - Vitus
well actually - negative all right I'm
gonna write both leg it is because it
shows I know where this is coming from
on what one there it is
so now I know that alpha plus beta is
just equal so for right so now I know
just right away I know the y coordinate
of the midpoint done right so and a B is
going to be something
for yeah something for okay so how do I
find the other piece I've got what's
options here lots of lots of options I
can substitute this into the line a B
right because it's on a B right
the only problem with that is I don't
know what a B is at least I don't know
it yet and I would have to find that
okay
is there a simpler way I could do this
use the information I kind of already
have yeah do you remember we said before
if I wanted to find the midpoint of a B
it's going to be alpha plus beta on two
that's the average of the x-coordinates
isn't it so therefore it's just going to
be two right now think about this I
don't know if it's because you're still
wake you up I said to you oh we don't
know the equation of a B well you kind
of do don't you you just haven't you
just not thinking of it as a B let's
draw a quick picture because I've
deliberately sort of held off from
drawing a picture on this so that you
try and push through and don't see
things that are obvious it's going to
look roughly like this there's a
parabola that's big yeah use your
imagination there yeah there's that
straight line okay so where are a and B
on this diagram
there's the intersections right there's
one down the bottom left and then
there's another one
at the top right so even though it
wasn't called a B clearly the line y
equals 2x clearly that line is a B does
that make sense do you see how obvious
that is when you have a diagram and have
non obvious that is when you're trying
to like it's just a maze of algebra okay
so no one ever told you to draw a
diagram but I'm going to encourage you
to always do what even if it's only
rough like I don't know where these are
but I don't need to she's got a general
idea